[Música]
la naturaleza los animales son parte
importantísima de mi identidad de lo que
hago de lo que soy y expandir mi
concepto de lo que es naturaleza ha sido
súper importante para mí y quiero
contarles porque también es importante
para todos ustedes
esto puede transformar un día estresante
a un día bonito y además asegurar
nuestra supervivencia la supervivencia
de la gente que ustedes aman y la
supervivencia de todos los seres con los
que compartimos a este planeta
y estamos viviendo en un mundo
principalmente urbano en este momento
más de la mitad de la gente en el mundo
vive en ciudades
en bolivia alrededor del 60% de gente
vive en áreas urbanas y se proyecta que
para el 2050 2 de cada 3 personas van a
ser urbanas
ahora esto qué significa para la
naturaleza y para la gente
para empezar para la naturaleza
significa una modificación extrema tal
vez uno de los tipos más extremos de
modificación que hace el humano a la
naturaleza
además esto trae mucha reducción de las
funciones ecológicas que hay
naturalmente es decir se pierde la
capacidad de generar comida de generar
oxígeno o de generar el aire limpio agua
medicinas muchísimas cosas y por otro
lado las ciudades tienen una huella
ecológica enorme eso significa que
tienen un impacto muy grande en la
naturaleza porque todos los habitantes
que tienen las ciudades consumen
alimento o consumen energía materiales
etcétera y eso generalmente viene de
lugares lejanos que se te tiene que
transportar hacia las ciudades
alrededor del 80% de la energía del
mundo se usa en las ciudades que solo
ocupan el 3% del planeta para que les
den una idea
por otra parte las ciudades también van
a determinar nuestra salud física y
mental las ciudades concentran
contaminación acústica y lumínica
química entonces nuestra salud depende
mucho desde donde donde estamos viendo
de su calidad y la calidad de la
ciudades está determinada en gran medida
por la cantidad de naturaleza que
tenemos ahí
ya que más hay en las ciudades aparte de
gente de sus perros sus gatos y palomas
yo pensé que no mucho
soy bióloga y como la mayoría de mis
colegas yo pensé que las ciudades
estaban perdidas que ya no valía la pena
invertir tiempo esfuerzo dinero en
conservar estos lugares habiendo tanta
naturaleza que realmente necesita ser
salvada
mi ciudad en especial la paz es una
ciudad de las principales tal vez la
principal en muchos aspectos de bolivia
y una de las más altas del mundo estamos
a 3600 metros y por esta altitud y por
la urbanización acelerada y poco
planificada yo realmente pensé que no
había nada interesante que estudiar o
conservar en la paz
bueno para que entiendan qué es para mí
interesante necesito contarles que para
mí los carlos mamíferos carnívoros en
especial los felinos son el grupo más
increíble que hay son para mí tan lindos
hermosos y fascinantes como difíciles de
conservar y de estudiar la mayoría de
los carnívoros son nocturnos
tienen necesidades naturales bajas
tímidos entonces es difícil verlos por
eso lo que hacemos para estudiarlos es
buscar sus rastros es decir sus huellas
sus heces
es súper súper glamoroso estudiar
carnívoros como pueden ver entonces por
esto donde sea que yo estoy caminando
así cualquiera arena natural casi
automáticamente estoy mirando al piso
buscando rastros siempre sienta
automático entonces una en una ocasión
en la que yo estaba caminando en las
ánimas que es un área periurbana muy
cerquita de la paz de la ciudad me
encontré una un excremento de zorro
andino
en una ocasión que estaba caminando con
gente que estudia ves cuando todavía era
estudiante de biología
ese hallazgo increíble para mí más
muchas publicaciones sobre ecología
urbana que estuvieron saliendo en todo
el mundo y me hicieron dar cuenta de que
era muy importante empezar a estudiar
qué más había en las ciudades
y involucrarse más con la gente porque
la gente también nos hizo dar cuenta del
enorme conocimiento que tenían y el
enorme interés de involucrarse
es así
que considerando eso además de la crisis
climática por la que estamos atravesando
la crisis de biodiversidad con más de un
millón de especies en peligro de
extinción en todo el mundo de
desaparecer para siempre y la actual
crisis de salud que estamos viviendo
esta dolorosa pandemia que es prueba de
la relación enferma que obtenemos con la
naturaleza me hecho dar cuenta que
realmente no podemos enfrentar esta
crisis ninguna de estas si la mayoría de
la gente está desconectada de la
naturaleza y esa mayoría es la gente
urbana la gente que vive en las ciudades
solo sí
sí tenemos gente suficiente conectada y
que ama la naturaleza vamos a poder
resolver esas crisis
por eso cree he creado nuestros vecinos
silvestres
y con el equipo maravilloso
extremadamente inspirador que hemos
formado combinamos investigación ciencia
ciudadana y cambio y estrategias
estrategias de cambio de comportamiento
para concientizar a la población sobre
sus vecinos silvestres y reconectar la
con la naturaleza
utilizamos para hacer investigación
principalmente trampas cámara que son
trampas con sensores que detectan a los
carnívoros
los esperamos de esta manera los podemos
dejar y toman vídeos o fotos cuando
ellos pasan es mucho más glamuroso que
estudiar las heces por ejemplo entonces
así podemos saber qué hay en la ciudad
que hacen algunos comportamientos sus
patrones de actividad y muchas otras
cosas
por otro lado también estudiamos algunas
dimensiones humanas de la conservación
también incluimos aspectos culturales
hacemos ciencia ciudadana eso quiere
decir que involucramos a la gente de la
ciudad en la ciencia democratizamos la
ciencia la sacamos de la reducida élite
académica para que toda la gente todos
los ciudadanos y ciudadanas se
involucren y aporten activamente a la
conservación y hacer ciencia que cómo
hacemos esto con herramientas muy
simples como sus celulares la gente nos
manda fotos o vídeos de sus encuentros
con sus vecinos silvestres a nuestras
redes sociales principalmente y cada uno
de esos registros
es un dato valioso que nos ayuda a
entender cómo los animales están
gustando y se están adaptando la ciudad
además de eso y tal vez más importante
esta información ayuda a los ciudadanos
a tomar mejores decisiones más
responsables a las autoridades a
planificar la la ciudad considerando a
estos animales a estos vecinos
silvestres
también participamos por ejemplo en
eventos mundiales y en actividades
mundiales de ciencia ciudadana como el
global big day where reto ciudad
naturaleza en los que la paz ha estado
obteniendo los primeros lugares estos
últimos años
y hacemos comunicación difusión
educación con considerando los aspectos
por ejemplo de actitudes conocimiento
comportamientos de la gente para cambiar
eso hacia la conservación de sus vecinos
silvestres
entonces una de las cosas que
principalmente hacemos es devolver las
fotos y los vídeos que la gente nos
mandan con la especie identificada
y también información para que sepan más
de sus vecinos y como la gente también
puede ser buena vecina de estos animales
pero el lenguaje muy sencillo para que
alcancemos audiencias más allá de las
científicas también hacemos salidas a
áreas naturales a ver aves
principalmente que logran una reconexión
y un aprendizaje vivencial y así también
promocionamos las áreas protegidas
municipales que tenemos en nuestra
ciudad y los alrededores participamos
también en ferias difundimos nuestro
nuestros avances en materiales de
comunicación científica y no científica
entonces así la gente de la ciudad se ha
estado conectando con sus vecinos
silvestres se sorprende muchísimo se
alegra cuando nos cuentan que han visto
por ejemplo una cámara en el medio de la
ciudad un murciélago que come insectos
en sopocachi y un búho en calacoto
descansando unas vizcachas en el
cementerio jardín dándose un almuerzo
unos flamencos en la laguna de achocalla
que es muy cerca de la ciudad y hasta
unos ibis pont años haciendo una
paradita en el estadio hernando siles
sin fútbol y no sólo eso gracias a
muchos colegas sabemos ahora que tenemos
más de 150 aves en el valle de la paz
entre las que si consideramos los
migrantes y las que nos visitan
ocasionalmente además de más de 150
especies de otros vertebrados como
reptiles como anfibios carnívoros peces
y quién sabe cuántos insectos es algo
que todavía ni siquiera sabemos y seguro
con la ciencia ciudadana vamos a estar
averiguando y qué hace esto eso hasta
que la gente urbana se reconecte con la
naturaleza y eso hace que puedan actuar
de forma más responsable en su día a día
y otra cosa importante es que la puede
esta gente puede generar presión social
las ciudades son centros de decisión la
paz es la sede de gobierno por ejemplo
entonces las decisiones que se toman en
las ciudades pueden ir mucho más allá de
sus fronteras a nivel de políticas de
conservación es muy importante
y a su vez esto logra que poco a poco
las ciudades sean más biodiversas y más
verdes lo que hace que en las funciones
ecológicas se restauren eso quiere decir
que vamos a tener más vegetación que va
a refrescar nuestro ambiente porque
somos islas de calor las ciudades van a
refrescar nos va a dar sombra va a
limpiar nuestro aire para cuidar nuestra
agua va a agarrar nuestros suelos para
evitar los deslizamientos y muchísimas
cosas nos van a ver muchos vecinos
silvestres aves insectos roedores hasta
zorros que van a ayudarnos a polinizar
ya dispersar la comida que comemos que
se siembre alrededor de nuestra ciudad y
dentro en los huertos urbanos por
ejemplo y plantas ornamentales también
entonces además de eso algo
importantísimo es que mejora nuestra
calidad de vida
toda esta vegetación limpia nuestro aire
limpia la contaminación mejora nuestra
salud física
muy importante nuestra salud mental está
demostrado que en un contacto diario con
la naturaleza hace que mejoremos
nuestros niveles de estrés nuestros
niveles de aprendizaje en nuestra
felicidad entonces es posible lograr
ambientes urbanos más saludables y más
felices de esta manera muchas veces
estoy caminando estrés a dizzy ma
apurada en la ciudad y de pronto escuchó
un picaflor típico honor más grande del
mundo ya sabe reconocerlo y entonces
buscó dónde está lo veo y es un respiro
no me vuelvo a estar presente me resetea
y luego ya puedo volver a hacer lo que
estaba habiendo perdido pero sonriendo
estoy tranquila y no soy solo yo la
gente igual piensa en ahorita imaginen
rapidito su parque favorito en la ciudad
usuaria protegida lo que sea en la
ciudad que sienten
y ahora imagínense en el medio de la
ciudad en hora pico que siente
es bien importante también entender que
interesarnos en las ciudades no
significa que olvidarnos de la
naturaleza que está más lejos yo hago
las dos cosas yo trabajo combatiendo
ayudando a combatir el tráfico de vida
silvestre en especial jaguares amo mi
trabajo amo los jaguares a nuestra
naturaleza distante pero también amo la
naturaleza detesta cuando salgo de mi
casa cada día y más allá de eso las
acciones en la ciudad en las ciudades
son iguales determinantes que en esas
áreas lejanas porque porque esas
presiones sobre esas áreas vienen de las
ciudades a las ciudades llegan los
animales traficados desde ahí la madera
traficada el oro y otros minerales que
se extraen de ahí la energía que se
produce en las represas que se
construyen ahí y todas esas presiones
pueden bajar un poco si la gente de las
ciudades están más conscientes a dico y
conectada con la naturaleza y además de
eso pues esta misma gente puede apoyar
acciones de conservación en estos
lugares
entonces es clave
además pueden convertirse las ciudades
en pequeñas islas que pueden ir
recolectando y conectando estas áreas
lejanas como corredores entonces
necesitamos reducir o redefinir la
naturaleza si seguimos pensando que la
naturaleza es una cosa distante que no
ha tocado el humano no existe ya
naturaleza así ni un milímetro del
planeta es así ya no
incluso los bosques más remotos donde
todavía no ha llegado a ninguna persona
ahí si ha llegado el cambio climático
que es causado por la humanidad
por otro lado
mostrar que la naturaleza hay perdón en
la ciudades hay naturaleza
potenciarla visibilizarla le da la
oportunidad de la gente que no puede
viajar lejos por plata por tiempo por lo
que sea de tener ese contacto tan
importante a diario si la gente no tiene
ese contacto no le importa lo que pase
ni cerca ni lejos es clave
las ciudades también son ecosistemas dan
muchas muchas oportunidades y las
sabemos aprovechar
saliendo en la jardinera de tu casa al
frente puedes ver naturaleza y puedes
ver la evolución en todo su esplendor
puedes ver oxígeno produciéndose gases
de efecto invernadero absorbiendo se
polluelos naciendo semillas germinando
suelo generando sed
todos esos procesos al frente de tu casa
podemos cambiar el metabolismo de las
ciudades de ciudades que destruyen la
biodiversidad que empeoran la
contaminación y la crisis climática con
gente enferma estresada que vive en
lugares muertos a ciudades vivas que
reflejan nuestro amor innato por la
naturaleza con gente saludable con gente
feliz que está conectada con su vecindad
silvestre y esto nos va a beneficiar de
muchos de muchas maneras desde una
pequeña abeja hasta un imponente águila
estos vecinos silvestres son unos
recordatorios de lo que está más allá de
nuestra esencia de lo que está en juego
y de nuestra propia supervivencia les
invito a asombrarse inspirarse gracias